parís como no se veía hace meses barcos
llenos de turistas suben y bajan por el
senado las calles están llenas de gente
del mundo entero yo soy de azerbaiyán yo
soy de abrasivo yo soy de alemania somos
de suiza pero faltan dos naciones rusia
y china cuyos ciudadanos representaron
el 2% de los turistas de francia en 2019
también representaron el 6% del gasto de
los turistas estando más de 3 mil
millones de euros en este castillo
histórico a 50 kilómetros de parís su
ausencia se siente a diario los turistas
chinos solían representar el 10 por
ciento de los visitantes una de las
excepciones
de chará fue tenemos un terreno bastante
excepcional con jardines y la
arquitectura del edificio
los turistas eran en su mayoría
extranjeros y les gustaba alquilar el
recinto por lo excepcional que es la
excepción un castillo por el que muchos
pagarían cientos de miles de euros para
casarse
no ha habido ninguna boda aquí desde
marzo de 2019 por culpa del cob y las
próximas bodas que tengamos serán quizás
en octubre de 2022 estos eventos
privados suponían el 12 por ciento de
sus ingresos la pandemia hizo que los
turistas chinos dejarán de visitar
francia y desde febrero el número de
turistas rusos ha disminuido
considerablemente en el sur de francia
decenas de yates están amarrados en este
puerto en tiempos normales uno de cada
tres es alquilado por rusos pero ahora
no hay reservas
la pérdida económica es difícil de
compensar en 2019 francia fue el país
más visitado del mundo con 410 millones
de visitantes extranjeros